Okay. So I'm going to need your sort of like
your help on this story. Actually
yesterday I was starting to work on today's
show, researching some stories, putting some
notes together, and I started getting emails
and tweets, probably about 10 or 12 in total
people linking me to the same video and it's
a video, a supposedly leaked video of Elizabeth
Warren talking to union officials in a private
meeting about healthcare. And the headline
was Warren bails on Medicare for all Warren
aborts, Bernie's Medicare for all plan, devastating
Warren caught and leaked video distancing
from Bernie's Medicare for all plan. So I
was ready to come in today and just crush
Elizabeth Warren for abandoning Medicare for
all with no specific alternative. And I was
ready to go. And then I watched the video
and in the video I don't see Elizabeth Warren
do that. I see in the video, Elizabeth Warren
say that Medicare for all is the cheapest
way to get the best care to the highest number
of people.
Wait a thought. What? How is that possible?
I thought it was devastating video of Elizabeth
Warren abandoning Medicare for all. I was
ready to just say, look at this terrible,
disgusting video of Elizabeth Warren. Then
I saw the video and I don't understand where
the headlines are coming from, so I need your
help today in figuring this out. We're going
to look at the video. The first question anytime
you hear about a leak video is, was the video
really leaked. A lot of things that are supposedly
leaked, uh, under the Trump administration,
we later find out are leaked by Trump officials
because they think that it's going to look
good for them or whatever. Was this video
really leaked? I don't know. If you believe
it was leaked, then you're probably predisposed
to assume that Elizabeth Warren says or does
something bad in it. I don't know if the video
was leaked from the recording. It seems like
someone is just sitting right in front of
Elizabeth Warren recording to the thing recording
the thing. I don't know the answer to that,
but let's listen to what Elizabeth Warren
says, and again, English is my second language.
Maybe there are some grammatical or linguistic
nuances here that I'm not understanding where
she says that she's bailing on Medicare for
all. I'm just not seeing it. And I want to
make sure that I understand this. So let's
look at clip number one.
I'm going to be out, if I can a little more
open textured about this one. The way I see
it is we to know what the goal
is and the goal has gotta be. Yup. We've gotta
be in a place where we get coverage for everybody
at the lowest possible cost and the numbers
are just clear on, that's Medicare for all.
Um, I, the Republicans put together a study
to show how expensive Medicare for all was
going to be. You know, they really wanted
to, they wanted to show us and it turned out
it was cheaper than any alternative that anybody
could come up with because you cut out all
the crazy billing, you cut out all of the
fighting with the insurance companies and
you cut out the $23 billion in profits that
the insurance companies sucked out of the
system just last year alone. And that doesn't
even count what they spent on CEO salaries.
Remember their basic business model taken
as much as you can in premiums and pay out
as little as you can in health care coverage.
Saying no is how they make money. So this
is not sustainable over a long period. So
we've got to figure out that's where we're
headed now how do we get there? And for me,
I think of it that way. I think of trade and
that is it matters who's at the table. I want
to make sure that the folks who are at the
table, our folks don't have healthcare coverage,
I want to make sure they are there. But also
folks who do have health care coverage.
Okay. So so far I hear Elizabeth Warren talking
up Medicare for all. I hear her talking about
lower cost and higher access and it's good
and she wants to be sure that unions who have
already negotiated health care for their union
members in many cases are part of the conversation
about what is going to be done with healthcare.
So you if we want to steel man, the worst
possible interpretation of this, she may be
alluding to. Unions may be happy with what
they have. Of course, most people are not
in unions, but I'm not seeing anything there
that matches the headlines that I was seeing.
So let's continue. And again, I was ready
for Elizabeth Warren's big abandonment of
Medicare for all. I was ready to come in here
and go point by point destroying her. We were
smelling blood at the David Pakman show, but
I'm not seeing it in the video. Let's look
at clip number two
for those for whom it is already part of their
compensation package. Then we've got to think
about adjustments in the law that makes you
are not just that out of the goodness of their
hearts that some employers will make up the
difference, but that that's part of the legal
structure for people who don't have any coverage,
we've got to make sure that they're represented
about how fast we can get them into the system.
So when I hear people say, well, we'll do
55 50 45 let's great if you have health insurance,
we gotta find a way to get people into Medicare
for all as quickly as we can.
So this is pretty uncontroversial. How do
we get coverage quickly to people? She's pointing
out that if you phase in Medicare for all
by going from 65 as the age at which you can
get into it, down to 60 down to 55 down to
50 that in practical terms, that's too slow
for people who don't have healthcare right
now. We need to do something to get them healthcare
more quickly. Now again, you could interpret
that as her saying, we need to do a full phase
in of Medicare for all, even faster than has
been proposed by some people or on the other
side. You could interpret that as we need
something else in addition to Medicare for
all, uh, because some people aren't going
to be able to get Medicare for all right away
if it's phased in over time. But this is not
exactly devastating. I, I'm just not seeing
it. So now let's go to the next clip. And
this is a part that she is absolutely getting
crushed for.
So it's not that I have a plan that says we're
going to do this part and then we're going
to do this part and then we're going to do
this part. No. Instead, my plan is we're going
to get to a table like this. We're gonna make
sure everybody gets represented. We're going
to understand the urgency of the moment to
get this salt, people who aren't covered and
get ourselves on a path where everybody can
get there and everybody can get covered at
the lowest possible cost. That's what Medicare
for all is all about. I hope that's a helpful
answer. Yes. Good.
So people are crushing Elizabeth Warren on
this part because she says, I don't have a
plan of doing this part. And then this part
and then this part, there's two interpretations
here. One interpretation is she has no plan,
right? That would be like the harshest interpretation.
The other interpretation, and again I think
there's some linguistic ambiguity here, is
she saying, I don't have a plan for a sequential
phase in, I need to get everybody who doesn't
have health care health care right away. She
is saying as I hear it, Medicare for all is
what we are doing, but we need everyone at
the table and slowly phasing it in with different
lowering age requirements is too slow. If
you have an acute need for healthcare right
now, I'm going to be totally honest, I don't
really see what the controversy is. This to
me is actually more strongly for Medicare
for all than what I've seen her say in the
past, which has been problematic.
So even if you interpret this in the least
charitable way, based on my grasp of the English
language, she seems to be saying she's open
to things other than Medicare for all continuing
to exist in parallel with Medicare for all,
for example, for who have healthcare negotiated
through their unions, which is a very small
percentage of the country. I think 8% of the
country is in a union and I, my guess is that
not that full 8%, uh, has guaranteed health
care as a result of being in, in that union.
Who cares? I mean, I think that from the beginning
I've said running on making private insurance
illegal is a mistake. Let the market dictate
what happens to private insurance. If you
put in a really good Medicare for all plan,
if private insurance is terrible compared
to Medicare for all, which it likely would
be, then people will get out of those risk
pools and that will make private insurance
even more expensive and that will make more
people get out of it and the market will actually
resolve that issue pretty tightly.
So again, I want your help. I just don't seem
to be understanding where in this Elizabeth
Warren is abandoning Medicare for all. I'm
hearing her in much stronger terms that I've
heard over the last three to six months from
her three months. I guess I would say be in
favor of Medicare for all. Maybe my understanding
of the English language is a a just not up
to par, and maybe that's where I'm, I'm missing
this. I want to hear from you. Where is the
big abandonment?